i was actually interviewed maybe people
would be interested i was interviewed on
the scrabble website
it was maybe kind of random but uh
i know there's there's a lot of people
in the scrabble community trying to like
grow scrabble
on on twitch and youtube
uh let me see if i can find this
interview
yeah there's a q a thing
uh i'll link this in the chat
it's my first time ever being
interviewed on a scrabble website
did it say expert chess player
oh hahaha this is actually a very common
thing
or common kind of what's the right word
mischaracterization of chess players in
media
because a lot of people don't realize
like expert is kind of a title
it's when you have the rating of 2000
um so i could take this as an insult
you call me an expert chess player
that's 400 points below my
actual rating but i know what they mean
so okay i'll leave this as a link
it was basically an interview that was
transcribed
so it's just text conversation
but i think we talked about some
interesting things
so some talk about like chess and twitch
and then eventually scrabble
is a hot dog a sandwich uh
it depends if the bread is attached or
not
because when you have a bun if if it's
attached
then it's just a hot dog but if it's not
attached
then it's a sandwich i think
but people can debate ferociously
also taco yeah taco is basically
taco is an anagram of coat
okay scrabble time let's go
we need we need a song let's do this
okay
boxer time
okay
let's play zigg or i have gauze
no let's play ziggy gotta score the
points
um i've cuties i have a cute
[Music]
no ah accuses two c's
i'll just play use
tantric
tantric is valid ah
i have tantric here let's go
also have tantric like this
okay good start
hmm i'll play okay
i've groovy
groovy
okay i've seen this word before some
french type thing
royal ah
does it fit
[Music]
no it doesn't fit ah oh it fits here
let's go
sorry if it's too loud
oh
i have no vowels what is this
come on
okay head by 40.
burke
[Music]
[Music]
god i'm losing
no let's play ah
okay okay focus sign
uh
oh it's so close
[Music]
oh we're almost at the end
let's go yes let's go
wow i got lucky there that that's this
fit
okay it's a close game that was a good
game i found some
i usually don't find like these long
words and bullets
yeah what does this even mean
it's one of these words like i've seen
before because it uses all
one point tiles um
i don't even know how to pronounce this
oh a peppery a peppery garlic sauce
interesting
oh hi to youtube yeah
maybe i'll put this on youtube i put a
video recently of me playing chess
to this uh this song
um this hall of the mountain king song
it's a nice song
oh it also means rust
yeah tantric was also nice
but the opponent fought back opponent
had pansies and sending
that was a really close game
i feel like there was a high quality
bullet game too
i'd saucier saucier
oh cauterize
cotter oh is that valid
it's probably valid wow
i missed a nine letter word here
[Music]
man
yeah thanks thanks for being here the
wander
people should should check out wander on
twitch very strong scrabble player
very capable of finding words like this
okay that was fun um yeah thanks again
to everyone
good amount of chess good amount of
scrabble